where we're serving we're gonna start
the meal with them with lardo that we've
cured from from Stone Barns it's
delicious fat and and ironically it's
probably the last place we should start
the meal but the lovers meal but we're
going to have we brought these like
really cool tweezers and the waiters are
going to go around to all our diners and
have a slice of just cured fat you have
to stick out your tongue and put a slice
of cured fat on right so it's a little
gimmicky and you know whatever and a
little corny but you know it gets people
in the mood of Valentine's Day plus it's
it's a local I mean it's a local it's
it's our own pigs and and they're
delicious and it's a way to sort of have
fun with it and then we also have honey
that we harvested in the fall from
someone's we've almost like 300,000
honeybees and so made this incredible
floral honey and so we're going to warm
it up a little bit have these like
paintbrushes and go around in paint
person's hand with a little bit of honey
so you can have to suck your hand to
start and then there's going to be a
shooter of sort of champagne kind of
tonic to start the meal so it's fat and
then there's honey so the meal is like
sort of in that it's like a little bit
fun and and and you know romantic and
so serious